codaf tu n as maya me isabelle roy lé
comme tous ces auberges d'une manette
merci que isabelle dans cette auberge de
luxe de montigny le bretonneux les
clients étrangers sont choyés cette
année ils se sont faits plutôt rares
une déception pour cette gérante qui
pensaient engendrer une hausse de son
chiffre d'affaires de 30% avec l'effet
euro 2016 du mois de juin sur l'euro on
a absolument aucun on a eu très très peu
de réservations par rapport à ça très
très peu du fait que vous voyez les
attentats du fait eu les grèves du fait
que au niveau image internationale on a
quand même beaucoup souffert
et puis les étrangers ont eu peur je
veux dire non forcément ça impacte et
paris et du coup ça nous a impacté par
ce que
logiquement quand tu racontes paris
travaille très très bien au niveau
touristique nous on a toujours des
retombées
isabelle fait désormais appel à des
tours opérateurs et pour attirer une
clientèle étrangère et familiale
l'accent est mis sur une cuisine
française de qualité pour les étrangers
jeunes arman c'est important pour eux
ils aiment bien avoir plusieurs desserts
goûter que ça soit frais et un peu
exotique à quelques kilomètres l'enjeu
est totalement différent pour cet hôtel
implanté au milieu d'une zone
d'activités la proximité de grandes
sociétés leur permet d'être souvent
complet du dimanche au jeudi soir la
semaine effectivement on a une clientèle
100% d'affaires et comment ça se passe
alors les week-ends alors les week-ends
c'est très calme
on essaye d'attirer une clientèle de
loisirs on a un petit peu de mal on
avait une clientèle étrangère qui venait
dans notre établissement
les week-ends mais suite aux attentats
qui a eu elle ne vient plus avec
l'arrivée des vacances scolaires
l'activité hôtelière diminue fortement
dans l'agglomération pour rester
attractif cet hôtel propose des
promotions sur les chambres allant
jusqu'à 50%
en attendant une reprise de l'activité à
la rentrée